so I mean it's like it kind of in
warrior traditions to give you these
sarcasm so obviously they could get in
your face I said I said fine that's fine
but a lot of times it's sarcasm you get
but why because you you got in the way
you apply got in the way and you
couldn't hear it didn't make sense
because you're prising the way so your
sensory input and your decision making
becomes unrefined and now it's a mystery
did you get that and so for us it's the
pride that self unrefined sensory and
the manifestation of the mystery it's
not the way do you understand so there
was no reason not to no it's fine
but it becomes a mystery this out happen
if you did understand mine quips
throughout the years that's what it is
and it's the same thing when you're
doing this technique wait why are you
doing that right after I told you that
because you your ego got in the way and
you can't sense that you're doing that
nor can you sense you're doing what your
teacher told you not to do all that goes
out and why because you're unconscious
so my awareness doesn't even extend to
the length of my body
how well are my senses refined do you
understand so you need to take those
little jokes a little more seriously
because it's not an innocent thing to be
unconscious but remember at the end of
the last podcast right I'm making the
point are you going to take
seriously what this man is saying or are
you just going to just continue to
practice unconsciousness unrefined
senses is there no sense of
responsibility in you to for you and for
the world to gain consciousness right
it's not as simple it's not a little
thing can you grasp at so with your
training pay attention you're using the
form as a tool for consciousness the
deviation from the form happens due to
unconsciousness so you can't just do
whatever you do the form and to hold
yourself to the form you have to remain
present mindful conscious can you grasp
that
you